Did you know 40%, 40% of Fortune 500 companies
in America are founded by an immigrant or
a child of an immigrant?
40%.
That's 200 of the biggest companies in America.
That's a lot of numbers there, right?
Then you hear Inked Magazine say that immigrants
are twice as likely to become entrepreneurs
than somebody that's actually born here.
Why is that?
Why does that take place?
Today I want to talk to you about the 10 reasons
why immigrants make great entrepreneurs.
If you have any questions, thoughts, comments,
make sure you post your comments on the bottom.
If you haven't yet subscribed to this channel,
click on the subscribe button here to see
more videos on Valuetainment.
Let me get right into point number one.
Thick skin.
What do you mean by thick skin?
Let me explain it to you.
There is something that happens when I grow
up in a very peaceful family with no problems.
Everything's covered.
Things are good.
Things are smooth.
Mom and dad never argue.
Everything's just chill.
You know those families that they talk and
just everything is easy going.
Now I want you to think about the other family.
Imagine you're in a family when you're escaping
a war.
You're getting bombed on every week.
Where your kids can't go play outside because
everybody's afraid.
Where mom and dad are afraid to go outside
and tension is higher.
You're working longer hours.
You ain't got time around your kids.
Your temper's shorter.
You got a shorter fuse.
You get upset at the kids a little bit faster.
You give them a look.
You push the kids around.
Parents have all this pressure on them and
they have to release it somewhere.
If the wife doesn't see her husband five,
six days a week because he's out there working
and the only thing he sees or she sees are
the kids, she has to release that tension
somewhere.
Where else is it going to go?
The kids gets it, right?
Now some people will only say, "That's called
bad parenting."
Unless if you've never been in a situation
like that, you can't say what it's like because
it's tough.
What happens there?
There's a big benefit to it.
Here's what the benefit is.
That kid says, "If I can handle living with
my mommy and my daddy, guess what?
I can handle anybody else because my skin
is so thick that your little rejection saying
no to my proposal means nothing, nothing,
because I can live in this family with this
mommy and daddy.
I can definitely handle you."
When you get thick skin, the world of business
is so easy for you because you're not worried
about somebody hurting your feelings.
Number two, patience.
In the world of business, you're going to
need a lot of patience.
I remember living in Iran 1984 and my dad
and my mom finally deciding to apply for a
green card to come to America.
We would watch Rocky in 1985 when it came
out.
We'll watch all these movies about United
States.
This is heaven.
People were coming.
They were celebrating about coming to America.
They got their number.
They got their free ticket to come to the
land of opportunities.
From 1984 we waited until '89.
Khomeini dies.
We don't have the green card yet.
Khomeini dies June 3rd.
Six weeks later we escape and we go to Germany.
I lived in a refugee camp in Germany for a
year and a half.
Then we finally get our papers.
Then we come to America November 28, 1990.
Took seven and a half years until we finally
made it to the States.
It requires a lot of patience until you get
what you want, same thing with business.
Number three, long hours.
Nine to five is an American thing.
There is not really a lot of nine to five
going on with immigrants.
Immigrants wake up in the morning and they
work until they have their money on the table,
food on the table, to go buy stuff, pay rent,
all this stuff with their kids.
There is no nine to five.
It's not like a nine to five in all these
other things you're dealing with.
You get to work and you come home and you
make sure everything is covered.
Typically, they're used to working six days
a week, not five days a week.
In America, they're trying to go to four days
a week.
They're even trying to write a book called
"4-Hour Workweek" by a guy named Tim Ferriss.
It's like work less.
Immigrants say, "Hey, everybody in America.
You guys keep working four hours a week.
We're gong to bust our behinds and guess what?
40% of Fortune 500 companies will be founded
by us and our kids, but you guys keep working
four hours a week.
Leave that market for us because we're not
afraid of hard work."
They bring that to the table.
In the world of business, if you ain't afraid
of this, everyone's going to eventually find
out about your business if you're not afraid
of this.
Number four, they value money a little bit
more.
Here's why, I remember when we were living
in Germany at a refugee camp and I wanted
to go to a movie, I don't think we ever went
to movies in Germany.
I don't think we ever went to movies in Germany.
If we even had a chance to go somewhere and
do anything with it, it was like magical.
I remember being 11 years old.
We played the first lotto.
I find out about lotto.
I had saved up five bucks and I went and played
lotto.
Sometimes people ask me how come I don't play
the lottery.
I went and played five bucks and I picked
these numbers.
I remember the numbers still today.
44 was one of them.
60 was another one.
38 was another.
I picked my mom's age at that time, my dad's
age at that time.
I came and I said, "Oh my god.
I don't know why I feel like I'm going to
win and we're going to be millionaires.
My mom and dad, everybody's going to be good.
We're going to be taken care of.
This is going to change our lives."
Boom.
We didn't win.
I cried all night like a little baby.
You know why?
Because you know how much was five marks to
our family?
Man, it was a lot of money what five marks
was.
When you come to the States, you value money
a little bit more because you work your tail
for this money so you understand we ain't
wasting this money here, kid.
We ain't buying all these nonsense stuff because
you value money a little bit more.
In the world of business, the more you can
know how to value, you know how to stretch
that dollar, your business lasts a lot longer.
Number five, they're used to taking risks.
Uncertainly and risk is part of the life.
I mean it depends on what part of the country
and world you come from.
I always like to travel and go different places
and ask questions.
What is it like living here?
Tell me about what the daily income people
make?
What is the income here?
We were in Cancun.
Tell me what people are making here?
I'm asking.
Tell me about what it's like.
They're so used to risk and uncertainty.
It's like everyday is a risk.
Everyday is an uncertainty.
In the world of business, it's the same thing.
By the way, most people cannot handle too
much risk and too much uncertainty.
Most people like a lot of things to be safe.
They don't like too much risk.
They don't like too much uncertainty.
That's why if you're going to get into the
business world and you don't know how to handle
this, all of a sudden it's a shell shock.
I can't handle this.
You go back to what you were doing before,
but immigrants already know how to handle
that.
Number six, sacrifice.
Sacrifice could be on a lot of different skills
by the way.
Time away from family, time away from partying,
time away from fooling around, so many different
things.
This is a must in the world of business.
It's a must for what immigrants do.
Imagine if you're already used to going to
the places you eat, churches you go to, families
you visit, friends, all this stuff you're
accustomed to living around for 5, 10, 15,
20, 30, 40 years.
Then all of a sudden you pack your bags and
leave the country and go to a new place and
you don't speak the language.
You know how many sacrifices you're making?
You're used to it.
In the world business, they make easy transitions.
A big sacrifice to somebody else could be
a small sacrifice to an immigrant entrepreneur.
Number seven, another level of commonalities
because of language.
Think about it.
Imagine if me, I remember when I joined the
army, I went to PX.
PX is military's Walmart.
I went to PX and I ran into everybody at Jackson,
South Carolina at the time.
Everybody was Caucasian, African-America,
Hispanic.
Here I am walking.
I go to PX and I see another guy with a crooked
nose.
I said, "Wait a minute.
I recognize crooked noses."
Middle Easterns we got this crooked noses.
I said, "Hey man, where you from?"
He says, "Where are you from?"
I said, "I'm from Glendale.
I'm half Armenian, half Farsi."
He says, "No way.
I'm from Glendale.
You got to be kidding me."
Boom.
We connected.
There's a relationship.
If we don't speak that language, we don't
have that connection.
It's a whole different story than friends
that also speak Armenian and Syrian.
I get connected to people that speak Farsi.
I get to connected to that because there's
another language you speak.
If you do business with somebody that speaks
Spanish, you can't get into the community
of people that speak Spanish.
I recently sat with a guy here who's from
Pakistan.
I said, "What percent is your businesses with
people who are Pakistani?"
He says 95%.
He can connect with an audience that you may
not be able to connect with because he is
part of that community, he's part of that
culture.
It helps in business as well.
Culturally, language, it helps.
Number eight, help businesses go global.
What's this Red Bull guy stories with Dietrich,
some strange last name.
The founder of Red Bull.
Interesting story.
He apparently goes to Thailand and in Thailand
they're making this drink, it's called Krav
Daeng or something like that, Krav Daeng which
in the language means red bull.
He says, "My gosh.
What is this drink made for?"
He says, "For truck drivers so people don't
fall asleep."
He drinks it.
He likes it.
He brings it to America.
He started selling it and puts Red Bull on
it and now he's worth $15.7 billion on a drink
called Red Bull.
You know how many billions of Red Bulls you
have to sell to have a net worth of $15.7
billion?
That's how many he sold.
What happened?
Globally connected.
He knows because he's connected to other places.
You're constantly in another country.
You're connected with other people.
You're not worried about going to another
country because you're already used to it.
He brings that idea back.
It helps the business out here in America
and all over the world because everybody now
... Not everybody, but billions of Red Bulls
have been sold all over the world.
Number nine, ownership matters to them.
Why does ownership matter to them?
We had a story of ... This happened where
we were at, but you here this in different
types of countries as well where you own a
property, all of a sudden the government comes
and takes the property away from you because
hey, we have a new law.
This is our land.
You can't do nothing about it.
Here you go.
This is what you got, one-fifth of what the
value is.
Hush.
I stay quiet or else.
Boom.
Give us the property.
It's gone.
Right?
That idea of somebody taking away your home
from you or your land from you, it's like
somebody's saying, "Hey, that's my girl.
Give me your girl.
It's my wife.
Give me your wife.
That's my wife.
What are you talking about?
It's my wife.
No.
It's my wife after now.
Here's 10 grand.
Walk away.
Don't complain.
She's my wife now.
The kind of stuff that happens when you ... That's
my wife.
That's my husband.
That's my ownership.
In the world of business, immigrants love
ownership because they're all about freedom.
I want to have control.
This is mine.
I worked my butt off.
Leave me alone.
Let me get to work and let me have the life
that I want to have.
Let me have the family that I want to have
because ownership matters.
That's why they like being entrepreneurs.
Number 10, they don't get spooked by different
cultures.
If a person is from Mexico, no one gets shock
when they meet me and I'm from Iran.
If I meet somebody from for instance Africa
and I meet them and they say, "Where are you
from?"
"I'm from Iran."
They don't get spooked.
If I meet somebody from Alabama and they ask
me where I'm from, I say Iran, they say, "Where
are you from?"
I'm from Iran.
What's the big deal?
"I've never seen an Iranian before.
This is what you guys look like," because
there's no Iranians necessary in Alabama.
A person who's an immigrant, they can see
anybody because look, I'm used to having another
kind of cultures.
I'm used to what it is to come to America.
I can handle anybody else because I've seen
many different kinds, especially myself being
an immigrant coming here.
I don't have a hard time transitioning with
getting to know other cultures.
I tell you all this stuff because you hear
all these talks about immigrants, entrepreneurship,
all of these things, but I want to tell the
immigrants something here that maybe you haven't
been told because it's always this idea about
immigrants make great entrepreneurs.
Let me give you one final thought to be thinking
about on immigrant entrepreneurs.
Yes, 40% of Fortune 500 CEOs are immigrants
or the child of an immigrant that started
the company.
Yes, over 10% of Forbes 400 richest men in
America, Forbes 400 richest men in America
are immigrants.
Over 10%.
Elon Musk is one of them.
Sergey, founder of Google is another.
There's a good percent of them are out there,
but how come not more and what is the challenge
with some other people?
Maybe you're watching this saying, "How come
not more?
How come not yourself?
How come not somebody else?"
Sometimes when you go from a horrible situation
you have to an incredible one, you settle
for good because it's still better than horrible.
It's like, "Man, oh my gosh.
I'm totally happy with what I'm doing right
now.
This is totally warm and fuzzy for me.
I'm good.
I'm okay with this."
Sometimes immigrants don't think big and they
settle.
You have all the abilities to become a successful
entrepreneur and go out there and win, but
you settle too early.
When you settle too early, you leave the upside
potential for somebody else to go out there
and capitalize on.
If you're watching this yourself saying, "Man,
I'm an immigrant.
How come this hasn't happened for me?"
Maybe you ought to start thinking a little
bit bigger.
Maybe you ought to not just say, "I'm settling
and seeing everything is working out.
It's better than what it used to be so I'm
happy.
I'm grateful.
I'm good to go."
Keep being grateful, but stretch a little
bit more.
Think a little bit bigger.
See about the bigger possibilities on what
you can do with your life instead of just
saying, "I'm doing better than my cousins.
I'm doing better than my uncle back in such
and such country.
I'm doing better than my dad back in El Salvador."
No.
You become the leader for everybody else because
you keep expanding yourself to want to do
even something bigger.
Again questions, thoughts, comment on the
bottom.
If you haven't subscribed, click on the subscribe
button and the notification button right next
to it to be one of the first to get notified
every time a new video comes out.
Take care everybody.
Bye, bye.